When we invented the smartphone we didn't quite appreciate what we'd started.
Liberating people from their desks was a defining moment in technology...
...that proved to be the kind of leap that would inspire a generation.
Over the years we remained focused on creating the tools...
...used by the people who make and build our world.
We stayed true to our values of security, productivity, and best in class communications.
There comes a time when every company has to evolve,...
...to become re-inspired by that which first made them great...
...and create a vision for the next leap.
We have been quietly pouring our heart and soul into the foundation of this next evolution...
...and have invested in world-class innovators to help us realize it.
From QNX, the operating system so stable, secure, and fast...
...that is relied upon by the likes of NASA to ensure the safety of human life,...
...to the astonishing tribe...
...who designed the most beautiful and functional interfaces the world has ever seen.
Years of investment, innovation, hard work...
...in the intense pursuit of our passion.
It's finally about to bear its fruit.
An all new flawless mobile experience:...
...solid, secure, beautiful.
Best in class communications backed by thousands of the apps and games you love...
...and a lightning-fast web browser capable of viewing every website in the world...
...with no compromises or limits.
Blackberry 10 has arrived.